This is England, right? And there are
just groups and groups of women in
hijabs, uh, full burkers going in and
out of the sea. You've got one woman. Oh
no, he's upset cuz he wants to see women
in bikinis. He's a perve. And he's there
recording children and women and making
it seem as if they're doing something
absurd.
Guys, before the video starts, brothers
and sisters, one Umar is working in
Pakistan with the floods that's hit the
country. 1,700 people have lost their
life. Millions of people have lost their
homes and been displaced. So the videos
that you can see here, the pictures that
you can see guys, is demonstrating what
one um is doing on the ground. We know
Gaza is important and we know what's
going on there. But brothers and
sisters, we cannot enable and turn a
blind eye to the suffering of Muslims in
different countries, be it Pakistan, be
it Turkey, the earthquakes, wherever it
may be, Afghanistan, so many other
places need our help. And I know all of
us have given as much as we can to Gaza.
But brothers and sisters, wahi, just
imagine your home wrecked. Thousands of
people have died. Your family members
have passed away. You have nowhere to
live. Brothers and sisters, they need
our help as much as Gaza does. So I urge
you guys, inshallah, it's 100% donation
policy. Donate whatever amount, even if
it's one pound. The prophet peace be
upon him said the best form of sodak is
to give water. Brothers and sisters,
let's give them food and shelter and
water to drink so they can overcome this
tragedy. Inshallah. I urge you guys to
go to the link and donate now. Enjoy the
video.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
we're going to be reacting to a
transformer. Today, he's a Christian
when he likes, he's a liberal when he
chooses to. Uh, so we don't know what he
is, inshallah. His name is Montgomery
Toms. He went to a Portouth seaside to
have fish and chips on the seaside, of
course, and he came across some horrific
scenes. Let's see what those horrific
scenes were.
>> So, I'm at the absolutely gorgeous
British seaside. And I must say, I'm
very pro- freedom. I'm not one to say
ban the burka, but this is a pretty
depressing site. So,
>> okay. So, he's depressed. He's
horrified. So, what did he see so
horrifying? Let's find out. This is
England, right? And there are just
groups and groups of women in hijabs,
uh, full burkers going in and out of the
sea. You've got one woman.
>> How horrific. You've got a group of
Muslim women in hijabs cuz that's the
dress code that is told to them by God
Almighty like the Jews, like the
Christians, the nuns, you know, if the
mother of Jesus, Mary, was in Bethlehem
in that scorching heat, uh, would she
dress up in a bikini? And what is a
bikini? It's his underwear. Yes, my
friend. You see your wife, I don't know
if you have one or a girlfriend. I
really highly doubt you know, you look
very u feminized for that matter. I
don't think you would have a girlfriend
or a wife. Uh but you know
her and underpants is what underpants is
what you call bikini in that sense. You
just change it. You just give it a
different It's like strip club. No, no,
no. It's gentleman's club. You know, you
just give these different words to it
and make it seem like it's it's okay. Uh
you know, but it's not for that matter.
So, as you can see, he's disturbed by I
wonder what are you a pervert? Are you a
perv? What was you expecting? Yeah, we
know that the western world likes to
sexualize women, you know, go naked,
sleep around with thousand men, do as
you please, etc. You know, it's all well
and good. Yeah, 100%. You know, so but
when woman when in Islam a woman is
honored, a woman is dignified, she's not
a sexual object that you put in front of
a chocolate bar or inanimate objects and
treat her like she's an inanimate
object. Oh no, he's upset cuz he wants
to see women in bikinis. He's a perve
and he's there recording children and
women and making it seem as if they're
doing something absurd. Why don't you go
to the 1900s and see how British women
were dressing up? They looked more
Muslim, my friend. They look closer to
the bulka than you could ever with the
bikini. Let's carry on. I hope you guys
enjoyed the video, guys. But before
that, please download the Salah Pro app.
Brothers and sisters, we are a charity.
All of our services on the app is for
free. Free kibla finder, no ads, free
salah reminders, encourages to pray,
tells you salah times. You can book a
salah instructor, a Quran instructor.
You can order a guided prayer map for
absolutely free if you want to learn how
to pray salah. videos on how to pray
salah, salah hubs, and many, many more
broken sisters. We are not an app that
shares your information with third
parties. All of our services on the app
is for free. Download it now, inshallah,
and enjoy, guys. Let's go back to the
video. Um, who's getting in with their
kids, fully covered up, and yeah, it is
just absolutely bizarre to say that I'm
currently at kind of a landmark of
British culture, which is the seaside,
fish and chips, just those beautiful
details of of English culture. And I'm
currently looking at a sea of mothers
with their children in hijab.
>> Oh, what's British culture? Can you tell
me a bit about British culture, please?
What is your culture? What is British
culture? Are you a Christian? If you're
a Christian, my friend, you have to
dress up in a decent manner. Okay. Can
you show me where in the Bible it says
you can wear a bikini? Can you please
tell me? Can you please tell me? The
mother of Mary shows you exactly how a
woman should be dressed. So, when you
come and talk about this, can you please
tell me where you getting the standards
from? And you make it seem as if the
Muslim woman is oppressed. Uh for that
matter, I need to ask you a question.
For example, you telling me the western
woman is not affected. Yes. By societal
pressures, by the beauty industry, by
the opposite gender. Yes. Being
hypersexualized.
Dehumanized. Yes. Pornography. Yes. You
dehumanize women. You insult women. Yes.
By telling them what you dress, the
lesser you dress is better. Who has
given this? Where did you get this
objective morality, objective standard
that the bikini is a norm and a woman
dressed up in a bini which is covered
properly, that's the abnormal
>> full burkers getting into the ocean
while their husbands just get in and
play completely free. And and as
somebody who's, you know,
>> I don't know what's talking about, mate.
When I go swimming, as a Muslim man, I
have to cover from my navl to my knee,
which means most of the times I wear a
swimming top and a bottom. Yes. As a
Muslim man, I'm told to be modest as
well. So again, it just shows you
absolute ignorance. I think I think you
just bored, you you know, I was just
trying to, you know, um, uh, suck up to
the far right. And, you know, you just
thought that's been popularized. So, you
thought, I'm here. I've got nothing
better to do. Ah, I know. I'll just put
this up. And most people were actually
slaughtering him, saying, hold on a
second. You're pro- freedom. How the
hell would you explain that? I'm pro-
freedom. Yes. Uh, but I don't like the
burka. It's scary. It's this or that. My
friend, make your mind up. What are you,
a transformer? Are you a Christian? Yes.
Are you conservative? Are you liberal?
Liberal? Are you a lefty? What the hell
are you, mate? Yes. What? What are you?
You're changing different colors that
depend on where you are. Make your mind
up. Are you a liberal? If you're a
liberal, what is your issue? They can
dress up how they like. Why is it when a
woman chooses to sleep with a thousand
men? It's all good. I don't know. To
your stands, you probably would have an
issue with that. Like I saw one post of
yours in the underground um talking
against the LGBTQ. Yes. Right. So, I
mean, I'm I'm on your side on that
matter, etc. But then you have issues.
Make your bloody mind up, man. You're
not with the left. Yes. What are you?
You're against Islam. Where are you? You
seem a bit confused.
>> A Christian and and not a fan of Islam,
but also very pro- freedom. I do look at
this and I think this is awfully strange
and awfully
>> I'm I'm Christian against Islam and also
pro pro- freedom. Are you hearing
yourself? I'm I genuinely do you know
what the hell you're talking about? Are
you a Christian or pro freedom? Because
Christianity is not pro freedom, my
friend. It's not pro freedom. Yes. I'll
be very categorically tell you, my
friend. Yes. Okay. It's told clearly to
the woman that she has to sh in the
church. The head of the house is the man
is the man. Do you believe in this
values? Oh no. You don't pro freedom.
Your wife can. No, no. Your wife has to
obey you. Your wife has to obey you if
you're a Christian man. What are you? So
please make your mind up.
>> Concerning. I must say there's
definitely a weird shift, cultural shift
and mass Islamification of the UK which
we need to push back against. I mean
what an absolute ignoramous my friend
look at your culture your culture do you
think your ancestors will look at your
culture with the pro-LGBQT
with giving the permission to minors or
whatever you want to call them to choose
to um cut off their private parts and
change their gender. Do you think this
is your progenda? Do you think wearing
bikini, drinking alcohol, gambling and
all these bloody um
hedonistic world view, world like
lifestyle, do you think your forefathers
in the 1900s would be like, "Yes, they
were closer to Islam than they are ever
to you, my friend. If anything, the
actual British culture in the 1900s are
is much more closer to Islam than it is
to your liberal freedom worldview. So
you're just an absolute ignoramist.
You're an absolute fool." Montgomery
Toms. Yes. Okay. That's what you are.
Okay. So, in a nutshell, I just want to
say go educate yourself, my friend.
Okay. And you're there like a weirdo,
like you know, uh, recording and filming
children and women. Okay. You're a
pervert. That I see as that. You're just
a perve who's upset that he cannot look
at the flesh cuz that woman controls her
sexuality and you cannot see anything
like you do with other women, etc. Yeah,
that's why you're upset. Okay. So,
firstly, find out what British culture
is. And I would say highly educate
yourself and if you want to have a
discussion with me, I'm more than happy
to invite you uh to Leicester Square to
our da table which we invite people to
Islam and bring your world views or
whatever you want to come with inshallah
and I can speak to Facebook if you have
the guts. Yes, I'm there every Friday
and Sunday and there's a challenge to
every far right any far right any size
any shape any color my friend come and
see me and let's debate it if you have
the guts. Yes, if you have the
intellectual bulls you intellectual
Till next time brothers and
sisters. Asalam allayikum.